mais ce chien bonjour ça va bien
monsieur chien les gens pensent
peut-être que vous êtes relativement
nouveau ceux qui vous connaissent pas
vous êtes relativement nouveau chef
mais vous êtes un vieux députés à 40 ans
c'est votre sixième campagne électorale
celle ci doit être beaucoup plus comment
dire
vous devez être beaucoup plus nerveux
parce que l'enjeu est énorme cette fois
ci non mais je suis très confiant dans
notre équipe de campagne nous avons un
très bon message de rendre la vie plus
agréable pour tous les kényans s'est peu
différent de les anciens le camping où
j'étais seulement dans une propres
circonscriptions mais dont je dois
voyager partout au pays
mais j'ai à faire visiter les quatre
coins du pays et les quatre coins du
projet parlons d'abord si vous le voulez
bien de pétrole hier l'actualité a fait
qu'on a beaucoup parlé de pétrole vous
avez répété que votre corridor
énergétique serait une bonne solution
pour qu'on soit plus autonomes les
canadiens mais pour ça faut que vous
convainquez monsieur legault de faire
passer un pipeline oui mais on sait que
les québécois veulent acheter le pétrole
du canada et le préfet le peintre
canadien au lieu de le pétrole étrangère
à ces mieux d'acheter de pétrodollars
botteur de saskatchewan de que de
l'arabie saoudite et le corridor
énergétique va la possibilité lampe
autorités aux provinces du caractère
régler toutes les questions environ
toutes les questions avec les premières
nations et aussi et donne la priorité au
québec pour partager son énergie d'hydro
électricité à les autres provinces
alors c'est gagnant gagnant pour tout
les régions du pays
sauf que s'il vous dit non avez vous
d'autres arguments parce que vous
pourriez comme premier ministre imposer
le pipeline irie
vous jusque là oui mais je suis toujours
optimiste et je crois que les joueurs
discuter je peux travailler avec
monsieur legault pour trouver le terrain
encore mais c'est une question de
confiance dans le système
si les gens de québec ty les les élus de
québec peut voir que notre système de
l'examination des enjeux en vue monter
son propre poste qu'il est propre que
les niveaux les standards très élevés
je suis sûr que le goudron du québec et
les québécoises pour accepter une odeur
qui va assurer qu'on peut acheter le
pétrole canadien
non là le pétrole l'énergie de les
autres thés et aucune bon sens d'acheter
le pétrole de l'économie de dans notre
chambre ou de larbi solide qu'on a
beaucoup de réserves de leiris aussi si
donc vous allez plaidé vous allez donc
plaider votre cause mais si jamais c'est
un nom ils ne veulent pas monsieur
legault ou d'autres 1er mai du québec
éventuellement disent non est ce que
vous pourriez l'imposé c'est ça ma
question
oui il ya beaucoup d or et de partout au
pays et même au québec et c'est une
question d'assurer que nos standards nos
systèmes sont à s'embrasser les gens
pour avoir le confiance nous respectons
les champs de compétence des provinces
il ya les champs de compétence fédérale
aussi les choses qui écrit pour le
premier est d'assurer que les intérêts
nationaux sont défendre et conserver à
travers sur les enjeux s'il ya des
inquiétudes sur une espère que l'autre
reprend un projet on peut le
c'est ce que vous nous dites sur cette
question là en terminale mais ce chien
c'est que l'intérêt national pourrait
vous forcer à dire we are pipeline qui
va traverser le québec vers un nouveau
brunswick et je vais tout faire pour que
ce soit bien fait mais je pourrais
l'imposer oui mais les questions s'est
il ya des inquiétudes avec une une
spécifique un projet il ya des
faiblesses dont il ya des inquiétudes et
à des des choses que le gouvernement du
québec a vu de changer sur une projets
spéciaux c'est le sait responsabilité de
gourmont fédéral d'assurer que le
système
tous les gens peuvent avoir confiance
dans le système et ça c'est mon
engagement avec tous les premiers
ministres je vais assurer que le système
de d'examination pour les projets comme
ça serait trop basse et assis à des
inquiétudes y est d'aider des choses
spécifiques sur une question
d'environnement ou des premières nations
on verra bien mais pour que les gens
jugent bonne question de clarté mais ce
chiffre devrait passer à l'économie
ensuite mais vous dites donc je pourrais
effectivement patients pipeline au
québec même si le 1er mai du québec est
contre mais comme j'ai dit et à des
échanges de compétences provinciales et
des chambres de commerce avait le dos
les choses qui est pourtant il y en a
une
le premier ministre au niveau fédéral
qui a un esprit de collaboration avec
justin trudeau maintenant je sais
qu'avec tous les premiers mineurs
chiliens il ya aucune bon relations et
les imposer son propre style et son
propre pratique on l'a vu ça dans les
autres problèmes avec une grand
constructeur nous respectons les
premiers ministres tous les problèmes et
on veut avoir un esprit de collaboration
non la confrontation très bien mais vous
étiez dans ma juridiction de pouvoir
imposer quand même des pipelines comme
si comme c'est le cas actuellement en
colombie britannique
monsieur l'environnement est ce que vous
croyez qu'à une crise énergétique crise
et que nous devons accélérer les
programmes pour tenter de sauver la
planète
je crois sincèrement que le changement
climatique et non j'ai très très très
important et aussi les gouvernements des
pays partout on ne réagit pas on va voir
à des graves problèmes de départ pour
l'environnement c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes contre le tac sur
le caron que justin trudeau a imposé
parce que ne fonctionne pas il ne réduit
pas les émissions on a vu ça dans la
colombie-britannique et on vous sert au
niveau fédéral aussi alors notre propre
plan a adressé le changement climatique
avec l'investissement dans les
technologies nouveaux taxe mais la taxe
sur le carbone comme vous savez si on
parle du québec
ça n'aurait pas d'impact votre décision
sur le québec puisque le québec fait
partie de la bourse du carbone
donc les gens ne paierait pas moins pour
le carbone au québec même si vous êtes
premier ministre
quand je suis premier ministre je vais
respecter les plans d'action au niveau
provincial
le message était très clair que si le
province du québec de suivre un plan ou
l'autre et la halle et là le doigt
c'est la même chose avec les autres
promesses mon engagement avec les
premiers ministres qui ne veut pas la
taxe robin et que je vais annuler le
temps dont je vais établir une système
au niveau fédéral qui était très
compréhensive et qui parle d autres
aspects de lutte et le changement
climatique dans un contexte global très
bien économie vous avez promis des
baisses d'impôts c'est peut-être
l'engagement plus important jusqu'ici
des baisses d'impôts généralisées pour
tout le monde c'est le premier palier
d'imposition qui baliserait
progressivement jusqu'en 2023
pourquoi donner des baisses d'impôts aux
plus riches en réalité ces baisses
d'impôt de manière proportionnelle
bénéfié allégeant de moindres revenus
bien bien
plus que les gens riches c'est une veste
un port universel et aussi j'ai fait des
autres annonces qui va aider les gens
avec les revenus - - o comme le crédit
d'impôt pour les gens qui prend le
transport commune on va avoir beaucoup
des mesures pour baisser les impôts et
il ya des chiffres qui montrent que
notre pays n'ait pas vérifié les gens
plus pauvres bien big est plus que les
proches de libéral oui il est rejoint
touché aussi parce que le premier palier
s'adresse à tout le monde
monsieur chère vous de prométhée en même
temps vous l'avais dit la chambre de
commerce de montréal il ya deux semaines
l'élimination du déficit dans cinq ans
maintenant
qui va payer pour l'élimination du
déficit parce qu'en ontario qu'au québec
parlez-leur d'austérité que les gens
vont bien comprendre qu est ce que vous
allez coupé pour arriver à un déficit
zéro
alors on va montrer où les eaux tous les
canadiens comment équilibrer le budget
dans une période de temps responsable
cinq ans au même temps qu'on va laisser
plus d'argent dans leurs poches avec les
grands déficits du jeune trudeau
l'édifice et nuire les programmes
sociaux c'est important de contrôler
décidé à éliminer le déficit parce que
sinon beaucoup plus de votre argent avec
propre et l'intérêt sur les dettes alors
on va montrer aux canadiens comment on
va le faire
ça va au même temps augmenter les
investissements dans les programmes de
santé et les services sociaux et notre
plan va être tout chiffré par là
chiffre d'ici la fin de la campagne
parce que vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire
au québec on avait dit oui ça touchera
pas les services en ontario aussi ça
touchant polyservices ouhlala les gens
disent oh la la
vous avez raison et il ya et c'est très
important pour nous de montrer ou pour
les canadiens de comprendre exactement
comment va le faire je suis confiant que
le canadien va accepter notre plan parce
qu il comprend le risque avec les grands
déficits pour parler les années après
très bien monsieur legault a parlé ce
matin à faire répéter les demandes en
immigration est ce que vous accepteriez
de le laisser baisser la catégorie par
exemple de réconciliation familiale
réunification familiale est ce que vous
lui dites oui à ça alors le
lettre de monsieur legault a sauté un
souvent aujourd'hui j'ai dit en passant
on pensait que je suis ouvert à
travailler avec monsieur le groupe a
assuré paul à québec pour avoir plus
d'autonomie dans le système
d'immigration
on peut on peut souligner le fait que ya
une duplication entre une évaluation
pour les travailleurs cécilia besoin
pour le travailleur un clip horaire on
peut limiter le double duplication de la
floride rda ce pacte les demandes de
monsieur legault qu'on peut retrouver le
terme comme une loi 21 je crois vous
l'avais déjà dit à quelques jours vous
vous êtes engagé à ne pas participer à
une contestation judiciaire
même si comme les autres chefs vous
n'aimez pas cette loi
oui à nous n'avons aucune intention
d'intervenir à cet enjeu maintenant
devant aller les coûts et les courbes à
trancher monsieur chiots en début de
campagne vous le savez vous avait
trébuché en tout cas beaucoup de gens
d'analystes ont tous avaient trébuché
sur la question de l'avortement vous
n'êtes pas sorti pendant 7 jours vous
savez que c'était un sujet d'inquiétude
pour toujours pour beaucoup d'électeurs
ma question et sa combien vous avez deux
candidats pour qui cette question
pro-vie contre le libre choix est
important pour le pourrait mais nous ne
demandons pas nos candidats d' de
prendre se prononcer nous avons pour les
écrits en changer pour notre parti sur
cet enjeu nous nous allons jamais
réouvrir 7,7 en jeu et si quelqu'un
lassé je vais voter contre je vais avoir
voté contre chaque mesure à chacun c'est
de rouvrir ce débat
ça c'est le même position pour notre
parti pendant les années et savait
inchangé sur cet enjeu bon mais ce chien
est ce que vous allez par exemple comme
sur un peu avait fait couper le
financement d'organismes en afrique par
exemple qui offrait ultime en des
avortements des femmes
il avait coupé tout le financement des
groupes qui offrait les emportements
autrement dit allez vous faire
indirectement ce que vous ne pouvez pas
faire directement non comme je n'ai rien
changé sur cet enjeu on ne veut pas se
débat et on va comme je t'ai pas dit je
vais voter contre chaque mesure de le
rejuger droit mourir rapidement il ya eu
un jugement important la semaine
dernière est ce que vous êtes prêt à
élargir les critères du droit à mourir
dans la dignité
oui alors c'est une décision d'une cour
ça va avoir un impact très significatif
pour le regio-tour les dames gurria a il
ya une revue un méritoire au niveau du
parlement c'est essentiel que le
parlement respecte les décisions des
cours et alors on fait une étude de
compréhension de cette décision et on va
voir comment le parlement
comment le gouvernement doit réagir pour
respecter les cool les décisions de
découpe
mais en même temps protéger les gens
vulnérables et assuré que les régies
fonctions mais mais vos convictions
personnelles est ce qu'il vous porte à
ne pas élargir les critères de l'inde à
mourir la position de notre parti et on
respecte la décision de détruire
respecte le fait que c'est celle
la loi du canada maintenant mais on doit
assurer que le régime fonctions parce
qu'il ya des inquiétudes il ya des gens
qui représentent les les gens honorables
qui veut savoir qu' il ya des
protections 10 à des architectes pour
protéger les jambes comme ça les gens
avec les difficultés de la santé un
mental aussi
alors comme j'ai dit on va faire une
étude compréhensive pour assurer que
notre responsable décisions et notre
fonction pour les canadiens une minute
questions en rafale rapidement très très
grande fréquence entre québec et toronto
êtes vous pour ou contre
je suis pour j'ai travaillé que j'ai
discuté c'est un jeu avec notre candidat
d'être arrivé à l'ancien maire je crois
que les investissements dans les grands
les projets comme ça et de la croissance
économique
troisième au québec est ce que vous
allez aider à le financer oui 3e et oui
absolument
parité entre les hommes et les femmes
dans votre premier conseil des ministres
on va voir des femmes extraordinaires
des femmes extras dans notre cabinet qui
va représenter tous les cavaliers et les
régions aussi mais pas de parité
pas d'engagement de parité j'ai fais ok
on va voir le nôtre le nombre des
députés que les viennent nous donne on
va voir les résultats des élections
mais je peux vous assurer que les faits
me battre pas d'engagement précis mais
vous allez voir
et puis le pote est ce que vous allez
rouvrir parlant de rouvrir le débat pour
ouvrir le débat
est ce que vous allez rouvrir le débat
sur le patin et revenir sur l'addition
de décriminaliser sur la question de la
légalisation
g j'ai discuté cet enjeu avec monsieur
legault et les autres premiers s'il ya
des des conséquences de leur manière que
le libéral égaliser le pape et je suis
ouvert à les idées des autres grands
pour protéger les gens pour nous voir
santé mais on va parler
et si le cannabis est terminée vous
aurez d'ailleurs le même temps je le dis
aux gens avec monsieur trudeau que l'on
veut faire plus tard cette semaine dans
15 minutes 30
il leur 15 mai une trentaine de chiens
chef du parti conservateur du canada
bonne fin de campagne
merci beaucoup au revoir